امر وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي اثمار
بنكفير برفع حاله التاهل في السجون كافه
واغلاق الزنازين وهدد بحرمه الاسرى من
حقوقهم وذلك بعد ساعات من وفاه الاسير خضر
عدنان نتيجه اضراب عن الطعام وكانت مصلحه
السجون الاسرائيليه اعلنت انه عثر عليه
فاقدا للوعي داخل زنزالته بسجنه
واضافت انه نقل الى المستشفى ثم توفي
لاحقا من جهته قال رئيس الوزراء الفلسطيني
محمد شتيجيه ان الحكومه الاسرائيليه نفذت
جريمه اغتيال بحق عدنان عبر رفضها طلب
الافراج عنه واهماله طبيا الخارجيه
الفلسطينيه طالبت من جهتها بالتحقيق في
وفاه الاسير عدنان وحملت اسرائيل
المسؤوليه وفي سياق متصل دوت صفاره
الانذار في مستوطنات غلاف قطاع غزه في وقت
افادت فيه قناه الاسرائيليه بان الجيش رفع
حاله التاهب في صفوف قوات الدفاع الجوي
تحسبا لاطلاق صواريخ من غزه بعد وفاه
الاسير خضر عدنان
[موسيقى]
ومن رام الله مشاهدينا ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه عبد الحفيظ جعوان اهلا بك على طول
حفيظ والى اين وصلت داعيات وفاه خضر عدنان
حتى الان
ميدانيا حتى هذه اللحظه هناك حاله من
الغضب والحزن الشعبي على مصير خضر عدنان
ترجمت هذه الحاله الى تظاهرات ووقفات في
معظم المدن الفلسطينيه تحولت في الكثير
منها الى مواجهات مع القوات الاسرائيليه
خصوصا هنا شمال مدينه رام الله او في
مدينه الخليل وبعض الكره القريبه من مدينه
بيت لحم اضافه لعمليه اطلاق نار حدثت صباح
هذا اليوم على سياره تقلها
سياره مستوطنين اضافه لاطلاق ثلاثه
مقذوفات صاروخيه من قطاع غزه باتجاه
مستوطنات الغلاف حاليا وفق مصادر عبريه
ايضا تقول ان مصر تحاول ان تلعب دورا
كبيرا في يعني الوساطه بين حركه الجهاد
التي يتبع لها خضر عدنان وايضا اسرائيل في
محاوله لمنع تصعيد صاروخي على قطاع غزه
فمن جانب تحاول ان تضغط على اسرائيل
لتسليم جثمان خضر عدنان ومنع من تشريح هذا
الجثمان وتسليمه لذويه لتشييعه وايضا
تحاول ان تضغط على الجهاد مقابل ذلك لمنع
رد صاروخي على اسرائيل بسبب ما حدث مع خضر
عدنان هذه الاحداث طبعا ممكن ان تطور ايضا
لما بالموازاه بما يجري في داخل السجون
الاسرائيليه حاله استنفار كبيره وغضب
كبيره ينفذها الاسرى الفلسطينيون وهم
يدرسون الان ما هي الخطوات القادمه التي
يمكن ان يقوموا بها استنكارا لما حدث مع
خبر عدنان طبعا هذا يضاف كله الى الجهود
الدبلوماسيه التي
والسياسيه التي تبذل الفلسطينيه من وزاره
الخارجيه ومن مؤسسات حقوقيه ايضا التي
تطالب مؤسسات دوليه بالتحقيق فيما حدث مع
خضر عدنان وهو امر يعني غير مسبوق في
تاريخ الحركه الاسيره الفلسطينيه ان يقضي
اسيرا فلسطينيا جوعا في معركه الاضراب عن
الطعام لم يوما صحيح ان اسرى اخرين كانوا
قد قضوا في اضرابات على الطعام ولكن كانوا
نتيجه تداعيات الاضراب عن الطعام او تم
تعذيبهم او اطعمهم كسرا ولكن ان يقضي
اسيرا جائعا لمده لهذه المده في زنزانته
هذه ربما تحدث المره الاولى في التاريخ
الفلسطيني منذ الاحتلال عام 1967 وبالتالي
وقع هذا الحدث كان كبيرا جدا وتحديدا مع
شخصيه خضر عدنان الذي خاض خمس اضرابات
سابقه عن الطعام ويعتبر هو مفجر حاله
الاضراب الشخصيه عن الطعام سبق وكان عده
اضرابات على الطعام للحركه الاسيره
الفلسطينيه ولكن للمره الاولى كان قدر
عدنان يخوض اضرابا فرديا عن الطعام عام
2012 وبعده عشرات الاسرى ممن خاضوا هذه
الحاله من الاضرابات الفرديه وكانت ضد
اعتقالهم تحديدا الاعتقال الاداري وهو ما
تقوم به اسرائيل اعتقال الفلسطينيين بدون
تهمه وبالتالي ننتظر يعني هذا المساء اذا
كان هناك تصعيد على قطاع غزه ومن كانت
فصائل فلسطينيه ومجموعات مسلحه قد هددت
ايضا تحديدا في محيط مدينه جنين ومدينه
نابلس بتنفيذ عمليات انتقاميه لما جرى مع
خبر عدنان لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات